it's not the script for the new Star
Wars movie oh yeah taping this [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] what's up this is Method Man and
I'm going undercover on the Internet
it's actually me believe it it's
actually me coral it's Method Man the
leader of the wu-tang clan no I'm not to
leave ain't no leader in the wu-tang
clan we all general by default here I'm
saying we all bosses but resistant de
facto leader how about that that's all
that's a word right the fact though I
usually write Twitter it's actually me
oh yeah
is Elijah Wood just lurking in the
background of that Method Man classic
black cloth cypher you know what I think
he time slipped there cuz I don't
remember Elijah would be in it let's
start the conspiracy now no actually he
was there that was Elijah Wood he's a
certified hip hop head I actually worked
with him on a black and white James
Tobin fun fat Elijah Wood is a DJ and he
likes sex with various people men random
times I made that up met the man's first
one to Potts my made-up or his verse on
big E's to what I like I'm both honestly
I was a little bit more relaxed had a
little bit more time to write you know I
was hanging with the door panels my
biggie that was like my second encounter
with him but it was a comfortable
environment I knew who I was and [ __ ]
and now we both for our versus dead and
but if I have to pick one
the what has a way better be especially
with the vs. reddit they sell [ __ ]
already sitting on play why does Method
Man get his own song cuz I wrote it
that's the bottom line the reason why
that that song is called Method Man is
cuz I [ __ ] wrote it and it was hot so
there
go take your humble pie in the corner
needed
[Music]
did y'all know that method was slang for
PC PE back in the 90s
no it wasn't that's a false sword right
there no it wasn't we used to call
methods cigarettes first and then it
became weed so somebody like you brah
hey when people make up random [ __ ] they
used to call it Sherm water wet primo
button that the danger does is such a
but in Staten Island they call the
method you find me one [ __ ] from
Staten Island that ever called Gus
method me never call that [ __ ] met this
[ __ ] out himself stupid not really took
offense to that [ __ ] [ __ ] are you more
poor who went up the entire wu-tang clan
for Hunger Games style I'm about to say
me I don't want that what does the cow
stand for when it comes to rapper Method
Man taking into consideration all lives
how about that how come Redman and
Method Man never collabed with Jay and
Silent Bob in a video
I guess the opportunity never actually
presented itself but we are going to be
in their upcoming movie being a Silent
Bob renewed shout-out to Kevin Smith
shot 2j news that submitted more Twitter
this is the same from Luke Cage the dude
on the right has met the man who's
playing himself
Method Man exists in the MCU only
problem he's a member of wu-tang clan a
group that includes Ghostface Killah aka
Tony Stark aka Iron Man I don't see the
problem here you know we got a rapper
named 50 sick and he had an actual dude
named 50 cent I don't see the problem
Ghostface his name actually Tony Stark's
he's paying homage to the actual Tony
Stark's
and if you check the B footage and the
first Iron Man movie Ghost makes an
appearance so who bit who really the
whole thing does exist in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe yes we do even though
I'm slated to play bishop in the next
x-men movie because I said so
as David Simon why did slim Charles kill
cheese on the wire and didn't Method Man
audition for the role she's had to go
anybody that'll do
file today family like that he can't he
can't be allowed to stick around you
know Joe was a staple in that community
as far as not just drug dealing and
stuff like that but as far as of taking
carries on very family-oriented so to be
stabbed in the back by your own family
member yeah you can't live on the
streets like that that's the street code
ain't no yes I did audition for the role
but it wasn't for the role of cheese
cheese just came along at all I tribute
that - Nina Kay Nobu David you know
being great people give me a shot but
also our lexiflow believe the casting
director I get quiet around white people
reserved around white people but David
always gave that energy way I could be
me like usually played uncle yes sir
next up I commented math documentary
description wasn't an Oscar to did that
because that's right there it's in the
title of the strip game can't be having
strippers winning Oscars and [ __ ] like
that even though it's hard out here poor
kept won an Oscar shout out three 6
mafia word how Dave he's gonna play met
the man with Method Man could play
Method Man I see this has come up a lot
I can not play myself as young myself
and it wouldn't even look I saw it as an
opportunity for somebody who that's like
myself when I first got into it because
there weren't a lot of people giving you
the chance to show that you can do it so
when I seen Dave's name and the pot I
was like yeah he's just like me and he
wants to be an actor [ __ ] give him a
shot your question has no validity as
far as I go I am DB now that sounds like
a bondage site nicknamed Johnny Blaze
hot nickel-iron long to couch I'll call
- can you stand up anybody Johnny danger
blazing team is it never was mitzvah met
cacao mister meth meth
yeah that's about right a lot of missing
I got so many more cows
big dick daddy even bigger dick daddy
you know I ain't had a lot on me [ __ ]
you know yeah I could have replaced
medicine with one of them daddy names
and [ __ ] histogram
yo is this your company they have me on
a meal prep and posting they give me
free food symbol is that more cool they
met the man see the guy poisonous drink
in the movie belly I should have I
should have expected that but no I
didn't let the man didn't see that
because uh
Method Man wasn't there that was shot me
you know y'all got to differentiate
between reality and fantasy
alright nothing man wasn't there I was
shot meat that was there and no she
didn't see him poison a drink or else he
wouldn't drink it and another thing
how did shot meat survive getting poison
as well as shot answer that question one
there wasn't poison it was a sedative
the shot however where I get shot with
the shotgun it wasn't in the budget for
us to show that I had a vest on so there
is your question answered what are some
valuable business lessons one can learn
from the wu-tang clan diversify your
funds [ __ ] period this has met the man
right here thank you guys for all the
questions I just found some things out
about myself that I didn't even know I'm
actually playing boba fett in the next
Star Wars movie isn't that great let the
man son and all these